let's do this heart auscultation quiz so
you take your stethoscope and you place
it here to the left of the sternal
border at the second intercostal space
What valve listening Point are you
auscultating is it the mitral the aortic
pulmonic or tricuspid the answer is
pulmonic so how do you keep all these
heart auscultation sides together well
try remembering the mnemonic all
patients take medicine so here we have
on the right side just along that
sternal border at the second intercostal
space the aortic and then right across
from that we have the pulmonic which is
found on the left of the sternal border
at the second intercostal space and then
you go down a little bit to that fourth
intercostal space right next to that
sternal border and then you have the
tricuspid and then lastly at the left so
same side of the fifth intercostal space
But at the midclavicular line you have
the mitral